so here's a hypothetical let's say
you're a 25-year-old adult male living
in Compton California and you flip
burgers for a living and then one day
after a fight with your parents or your
siblings or whoever you decide that
you've had enough of the day-to-day and
you get uh you get maybe you get a
little high and and uh you decide that
you're going to be a noow at work and
you go for I don't know a road trip with
your friends to Las Vegas for a long
weekend it's all very fun and
irresponsible behavior and and as it
happens it's not exactly unheard of in
places like Compton and let's say that
you're boss at the Burger Shop notices
that you didn't show up for work and he
reports you missing and following
company protocol he calls the police and
he tells them that you've gone awall he
says he has no idea why this is
happening or what's going on but you
didn't show up well how should law
enforcement respond in that
situation starting next summer in the
biggest state in the country the answer
to that question will depend on one
thing your skin color if you're black
the cops will respond to your boss's
call by buzzing every cell phone in the
state telling millions of people to be
on the lookout for you state authorities
will plaster your name and description
all over Billboards on the interstates
they'll even put you on television in
the ticker at the bottom of all the
college football games that's if you're
black to be clear now if you happen to
be white on the other hand well it's
it's a different story if you're white
the authorities will do precisely none
of that instead they'll probably just
hang up the phone and tell the pizza guy
that he's uh wasting their time now if
sounds farfetched you should know that
actually it's not it is in fact what's
coming very soon in the state of
California it's the result of a new law
that was just signed by California's
governor and future presidential
candidate Gavin Newsome under this law
if black people under age 25 um go
missing for any reason then law
enforcement has the authority to issue
something called and and and I'm not
making this name up it's called an ebony
alert it's kind of like an amber alert
but in several key respects it's very
different watch on our new tonight
Governor Nome signed a law that can help
track down young people of color who
have disappeared tonight we're getting
answers on how the new Ebony alerts will
work and who can benefit from them
California now has a new tool to help
find missing black youth Amber Alerts
have been around for two decades and
since that time more than 370 children
and at risk individuals have been
located time is of the essence when it
comes to an actual alert but some
critics say African-Americans are often
overlooked by the notification system
you see the difference of when um white
girls go missing and um black girls go
missing the sense of urgency is not
there African-Americans whether their
children or young adults are often
listed as runaways state senator Steven
Bradford is the author of a new law that
creates ebony alerts for a community
disproportionately impacted by missing
youth African-American young individuals
make up almost 40% of those individuals
who come up missing it's going to put
significant change in how we react Barry
axus with voice of the youth says many
young women who vanish end up being
victims of sex trafficking here in
Sacramento especially a lot of our girls
get exploited in addition to Amber
Alerts California also has blue alerts
for suspects Who attack a law
enforcement officer silver alerts for
missing seniors and people with
disabilities and feather alerts for
missing indigenous people so how is an
eony alert different expanding the age
from 12 to 25 because right now a Amber
Alert is for 17 years or younger okay
all right so I wanted you hear all that
because there's a lot going on here
starting with the fact that California
already apparently has something called
feather alerts for Indians and now
they're adding ebony alerts to the mix
because naturally when you think of
black people you think of the word ebony
just like feathers come to mind when
you're talking about Native Americans
now I suppose there are probably more
stereotypical and insulting names they
could have come up with but these are
still pretty bad and for the record I
had to double check that news clip to
make sure it wasn't satire make sure
this wasn't some like way too on the-
noose Babylon B skit but it's real they
really have feather alerts out west for
missing Indians so people in California
will be sleeping or watching a football
game or drinking some zesty craft beer
then they'll get a feather alert on
their phones and they're expected to I
guess drop everything they're doing and
scramble to find some missing indigenous
person once they see a feather alert pop
up that that's that's a real thing that
happens in California at least since
last year when feather alerts were first
implemented and this didn't strike
anyone in California as being completely
and totally absurd apparently we could
speculate as to why that might be maybe
a lot of Berkeley grads honestly believe
that white supremacist Cowboys are still
out there tormenting the indigenous
peoples at every
turn whatever the case they do indeed
have feather alerts in California and
they're not joking about it this is
serious business now given that simple
if incredible fact you have to wonder
why California authorities haven't
deployed uh or maybe they eventually
will deploy a whole assortment of other
stereotypical alerts for every
conceivable ethnicity Under the Sun I
mean at this point why not keep going
they have an an an alert that's tailor
made for Indians and why stop there
possibilities are endless they could
have a general se's alert for missing
Asians for example they could Implement
a sombrero alert for Hispanics a
leprechaun alert for missing Irish
Americans
of course the left doesn't care about
two of those three groups this probably
wouldn't happen but given that that
they're now embracing every stereotype
imaginable in their quest to be
anti-racist it's not hard to picture
something like this down the line and
actually on second thought by the way I
think Kung powler has a better ring to
it and if they don't Implement that for
missing Asian people then at least this
would be a good system to put in place
for when the Uber eat driver doesn't
show up with your Chinese food order put
out the Kung Pow aler find your food now
at the same time if you paid close
attention to that news clip we just
played you probably have more pressing
concerns for example you might wonder
why black people need a separate system
of emergency alerts at all I mean for
one thing ambo alerts don't do much no
matter what your skin color might be as
a recent USA Today analysis found quote
Amber Alerts are extremely rare and even
when they're used it's unclear how much
help uh how much they help bring
children home
safely now on top of that the data we
have suggests that the Amber Alert
system is not discriminating against
anyone like in fact it's exactly
proportional so according to that same
analysis quote from 2017 through the end
of 2021 black children made up 37% of
missing child reports and nearly 37% of
Amber Alerts indicating the issues the
alerts are issued proportionally so what
exactly is the problem here it's exactly
proportional what conceivable reason
could there be to implement yet another
iteration of a useless system that
clearly isn't discriminatory in any
way well here's an NAACP Flack in
California state Senator Steven Bradford
who is uh going to try to explain that
to us listen the NAACP California Hawaii
state conference brought the idea for an
eony alert to state senator Steven
Bradford out of Los Angeles County the
alert would be specifically for black
youth and young black women between the
ages of 12 and 25 under Amber Alert
criteria they say black youth are dis
proportionately classified as runaways
criteria for the Amber Alert is that law
enforcement has to believe that there's
a suspicion of someone being Abdu
abducted as for the ebony alert we kind
of broaden that language too basically
if you're missing under a suspicious or
unexplained circumstance Senator
Bradford says for him the data is clear
although African-Americans make up 14%
of the country's population they make up
almost 38% of individuals who go missing
every year it's unfortunate that here in
California in 2023 that we need separate
types of notifications but we see
through the data that these groups are
being ignored when it comes to uh
finding them and dedicating the same
level of resources to help bring them
home okay so first of all note how they
frame this they say that these ebony
alerts are for black youth and young
black women but these new Ebony Ebony
alerts in California by law will also
sound for 25-year-old black males so
just be clear about that but moving on
what they're saying is that a lot of
black people who vanish aren't being
counted as missing persons and therefore
aren't eligible for Amber Alerts and
they're saying that's racist so
understand their argument you need to
know that in order for authorities to
issue an amber alert by law authorities
need some evidence that a child was
abducted or disappeared for some reason
against their will and yes it has to be
a child not an adult if there's no
evidence of that then the child is not
classified as missing they're classified
instead as Runway
ways and you know this you you think
this especially makes sense for adults
if a 24 year-old person goes missing and
there's no evidence at all that there's
any Foul
Play then in almost every case that's
just someone who ran off for whatever
the reasons are it's not actually an
emergency that the whole state needs to
be alerted
to in in the vast majority of cases if
the circumstances are like that so what
the proponents of ebony alerts are
saying is that the police are
deliberately Mis classifying black
people as runaways just to cook the
missing person's data because of course
the police are racist in fact that's
exactly what California legislators uh
say in the text of their legislation on
ebony alerts we don't have to guess
about this here's what California
lawmakers put in the bill quote being
identified as a runaway can also be a
legal loophole for law enforcement
because when a child is listed as a
runaway the police are allowed to delay
response and investigation time in cases
where the child is mislabeled as a
runaway this delay is crucial uh crucial
time that could be spent spent locating
a child in danger so they're just coming
out and saying that the police are lying
about the large number of black runaways
the cops are taking advantage of a
loophole in the law so that black youth
can be abducted without any
investigation they're saying that there
are that there are many cases apparently
where the police suspect that a black
child has been kidnapped and is in
imminent mortal danger and yet they just
classified as a runaway because they
don't care when black kids are kidnapped
that's what they're saying which is it's
a claim that's spelled out in the
legislation from the legisl of the State
of California they can't think of any
other conceivable explanation for why a
lot of black people might be unaccounted
for their theory is that all these young
black people are being abducted and
there's some sort of epidemic of black
kids being kidnapped and all the racist
cops have decided to conspire to hide
that
fact they know that all these missing
black people definitely can't have
anything to do with I don't know the
fact that 70% of black children are born
to unmarried mothers they also know that
it can't possibly be apparently related
to the fact that more than 64% of black
children grow up in single parent
homes you know which which the chances
of a child being a runaway when they're
when they grow up in a fatherless home
those chances are much much higher and
so it makes a lot of sense that if you
have a community where there are uh more
fatherless homes you're going to have a
lot more runaways all of that makes
sense it's exactly what we see in all
the
data but none of that is relevant in
their
mind instead California's legislature is
convinced that the problem is racist
cops who have apparently decided in
unison not to investigate missing
persons uh cases involving black people
and the California government's solution
to that invented problem is to implement
the same solution that South Africa
implemented long ago which is race-based
policing where people with preferred
skin colors are entitled to a police
response while people of disfavored skin
colors are ignored they're codifying
that into law with everything going on
in the world you know there's no better
time to build a daily habit of prayer
and meditation building a habit of
prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you're thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being Hollow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the US it's
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine can help you do the same
download the app for free at hall.com
Walsh you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way not
sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike Schmid's Bible in a year uh
podcast available on the Hallow app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cavel
and even some worldclass athletes with
hallow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using Hall to connect
with others who share your values and
beliefs can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
as well hallo just added a section on
their app called prayers for peace for
Israel and they have several prayers to
help people pray for peace in Israel
hall.com is what you got to download go
to hall.com Walsh you get an exclusive
three months free that's three months
absolutely free at hall.com
Matt Walsh here's the key part of this
new Ebony alert legislation in
California quote a law enforcement
agency May request that an ebony alert
be activated if that agency determines
that an ebony alert would be an
effective tool in investigation of
missing black youth including a young
woman or
girl that's it that's all that's
necessary there there's no requirement
that authorities suspect an abduction or
some kind of kidnapping that's the
standard for issuing a Statewide alert
for non uh black non-white people when
they go missing under the Amber Alert
System the text of this news legislation
in California admits that here's what it
says quote the Amber Alert System must
fulfill strict criteria for the message
to be broadcast if these criteria are
not met an amber alert cannot be issued
and the child is labeled as a runaway
but the ebony alert system does not have
to obey any such restrictions it's
enough according to this new legislation
for authorities to determine that an
ebony alert would be a quote effective
tool for finding a young black person
who's missing there's no other standards
outlined in the law just a a bunch of
suggestions the bill goes on to state
for example that if a black youth
disappears under unexplained
circumstances then that could be
sufficient to trigger the Statewide
alert non-black victims by contrast have
to show that they've been kidnapped
essentially so let's take stock of
what's happening the state of California
is taking a system that doesn't appear
to work which is the Amber Alert system
and they're duplicating it only this
time they're baking in a policy of
explicit racial segregation so they're
doubling down on something that that
doesn't seem to actually be
working classic government uh move there
and which is also becoming a classic
move they're they are racializing it now
it's not clear how this will work by the
way let's say a 17-year-old black
teenager goes missing does that teenager
get an Amber Alert in addition to an
ebony alert and for that matter what
happens if an elderly Native American
disappears do we do they get a feather
alert along with a silver alert is there
some way to combine all these categories
and have an ebony silver feather
alert all it would take is a is a
elderly black person who identifies as a
Native American and you know we can do
it we can achieve the singularity the
possibilities are truly endless or maybe
in that scenario the 17-year-old black
teenager wouldn't get an Amber an amber
alert because they're getting the ebony
alert maybe that's the way to work you
know if a black person goes missing they
get the ebony alert and if a white
person goes missing they get the Amber
Alert well in that case California will
have a established a truly segregated
emergency alert system with a separate
alert for whites and blacks at that
point they might as well go all the way
and change Amber Alert to Ivory
alert of course either scenario is
insane and counterproductive to say the
least it defies logic really I mean
think about it if you're really worried
about racist cops and Maga Republicans
who supposedly aren't trying to find
missing black people why would your
solution be to categorize all future
missing person alerts by Race by your
own logic now the racist cops and magga
Republicans can simply ignore the alerts
for whatever race they don't like so
you're making it easier in that
case again we can mock this all day but
all these contradictions and
inconsistencies aren't simply the
inevitable result of top- down state
driven social engineering they're also
the inevitable result of the worldview
of California politicians and liberals
more generally who refuse to recognize
reality even when it hits them in the
face you know the truth is that a lot of
young black people do run away from
their homes they do it voluntarily and
the reason they do it is that when they
were young their fathers ran away from
them it's a tragedy that repeats itself
generation after generation it's one of
the reasons every urban center in this
country is getting more dangerous every
year but predictively instead of doing
something about that problem instead of
addressing the crisis of single parent
homes in the state of California and
across the country Democrats have once
again decided to blame their political
opponents they're saying the cops are
responsible they're claiming magar
Republicans are behind it
Etc that's the explanation they've
settled on as a result a lot of
Californians are about to wake up at 3
a.m. to random blaring alerts on their
cell phones along with all the
earthquake notifications and the push
alerts about newly deposited poop on the
sidewalk of course many Californians
will decide to opt out of these alerts
indefinitely because they're too
constant and too annoying and a lot of
police resources will be wasted pursuing
runaways who left home voluntarily and
in the end black people will continue to
disappear probably at the exact same
rate unless something extraordinary
occurs this cycle will continue
unburdened as CA Harris might say by
what has
been for California liberals like ganum
that's good enough you know for everyone
else and especially for every nonbony
person who goes missing in the state of
California this sends a very clear
message is an explicit betrayal of the
race neutral system of laws that this
country has upheld for
Generations so this new law in
California I mean obviously needs to be
struck down as quickly as possible
should be condemned by every Republican
politician and conservative Power Center
in the
country you know a law that's that
explicitly says you if you are a runaway
you only get an alert if you are black
and not if you're white I mean that kind
of law should be condemned by everyone
and if that doesn't happen if your race
can somehow dictate how you're treated
by the police then nothing else really
matters I mean all the debates about
Ukraine and the debt ceiling and speaker
of the house they all pale in
comparison when they come for you
whatever that charge might be you'll be
judged on the basis of characteristics
you can't control if you're not
indigenous or a person of color then no
cell phone alert will sound when you
disappear there will be no signs on the
highway telling motorists to be on the
lookout for someone matching your
description you'll be isolated and
demonized and
condemned you'll be classified as a
runaway and forgotten
immediately which is a depressing
realization in some respects kind of
demoralizing but in reality it's
clarifying it tells you something
important it communicates loud and clear
the intent of the people who hate you
more than anything else in the world it
tells you that everything they pretend
is an injustice is in reality a
punishment that they desperately want to
inflict on you hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there